he's had a glittering career as a
fighter
and as a senator in the philippine
parliament
now 42 year old manny pacquiao is
running for the highest office in his
country he accepted the nomination of
his political allies during a national
assembly for the faction he leads in the
governing pdp laban party
we need progress
we need to win against poverty
we need government to serve our people
with integrity
compassion
and transparency
the time is now
we are ready to rise
to the challenge of leadership president
rodrigo duterte is barred from running
for another term but he has been picked
by a rival party faction to run for vice
president critics say it's an attempt to
cling to power in the philippines you're
only allowed to have one term six years
and um i think duterte is trying to find
a loophole in the constitution where
he could still
stay as president by having a proxy
candidate take his place and he
running as vice president and when that
happens if his proxy candidate wins that
candidate might be willing to step aside
and he takes the place as president
born from a poor family in the southern
province of bukidan pacquiao started his
professional boxing career at the age of
16.
he gained popularity with his frequent
victories and knockouts that have earned
him fans around the world
pacquiao was named fighter of the decade
by international boxing associations and
his fans called him the pound for pound
king
one of his biggest fights was his
showdown with american boxer floyd
mayweather in 2015 which he lost
pacquiao has won world titles in an
unprecedented eight different weight
divisions
but now he's facing an uphill battle to
tackle his country's numerous challenges
ranging from dealing with the covet 19
pandemic to corruption and gang violence
in 2016 pacquiao provoked a storm of
controversy after saying people in
same-sex relationships are quote worse
than animals
the road to next year's presidential
election will not be easy there are many
obstacles to overcome
but manny pacquiao already has one huge
advantage
millions of filipinos know his name dor
suchapari al jazeera